here you are safe for now outside of
this world is a very dangerous so please
be aware of infected you have only one
chance prepare your best weapons in a
car
be ready for a ride of survival
mechanics and a very least surroundings
and Landscapes so I don't have time to
someone else you can trust
listen to them carefully and let's
survive together
[Music]
waking up alone in a world that is no
longer recognizable you set out to find
answers in the resources to survive
the day before as a third person
survival MMO set in a deadly
post-pandemic America overrun by
zombie-like infected who have a taste
for flesh
but this isn't the only threat to
contend with other non-infected are
willing to kill for valuable resources
like food weapons and vehicles all in
the name of survival
first announced in 2021 the day before
continues to top the most wishlisted
games on Steam with a lot of excitement
surrounding this new MMO and with the
release date just around the corner it's
certainly hard to ignore the fact that
there is still a lot of unanswered
questions surrounding one of the most
intriguing upcoming games
with the infected everywhere across this
post-apocalyptic vision of America you
will be tasked with surviving in any way
you can
the game promises large-scale
exploration and drivable detailed
vehicles that you can find scattered
across the map or steal from fellow
survivors you can also steal other
players weapons in food it's kill or be
killed
you can of course work in a team for
survival and play with friends in your
attempt to survive by Scavenging for
resources
there's a colony of survivors in a
centralized Hub type area that will help
keep the calm in the middle of the
zombie-infested storm here you are able
to sell your collected loot communicate
with other players without the fear of
PVP gunfights join groups and Tackle
quests together
there is Base building like we've seen
in other games like Fallout 4 or State
of Decay and crafting using resources
that have been acquired
according to the developers themselves
they've focus more around sound design
instead of cluttering the player's
screen with HUD information
this decision may lead to a much more
immersive experience when exploring the
world
the combat looks relatively simple
centered around a fairly typical
third-person shooter that offers players
the option to use cars and other objects
as cover
but the developer has mentioned multiple
finishes or takedowns depending on the
equipped weapon
another part of the combat system is
that carrying too much equipment will
cause your character to make more noise
seems to be a large aspect of the game
where rooms filled with the infected can
be avoided in order to save limited
ammunition
also meeting players out in the world as
you're making the choice to either hide
and avoid the interaction team up or
take them down stealing their resources
think of this as the dark Zone but with
much much larger repercussions if the
fight doesn't go your way
other features the developers have
boasted about have been the game will
not include loading screens other than
the initial one when loading into the
game traversing through the open world
will be seamless and natural
you have the option to customize your
weapons based on the attachments and
loots you find
human NPCs outside of the Hub that
provide side quests and sell items
with a growing sense of anticipation
surrounding the MMO since it's reveal in
2021 there has been some skepticism and
controversy that has surfaced
shortly after the news of a delay the
studio appeared to be looking for
volunteers to help with upcoming
projects
the biggest sticking point was the
website's description of part-time
volunteers ranging from translating to
community moderating who received
non-monetary rewards such as
participation certificates and free
codes
reactions are varying across the board
but the overall consensus is that this
decision feels quite odd potentially
exploitative and doesn't bode well for
the game's intended release date
it's all kind of bizarre and raises
questions about whether this game has
been made by properly paid staff
the skepticism on the other hand is
largely due to the fact that we haven't
really seen all that much gameplay or
had any substantial information about
the game which is only intensified as we
draw closer to the release date
the most recent video which showed off
Ray tracing didn't show any gameplay
footage and fans appear to remain quite
skeptical on whether the day before can
deliver on its promises
the day before release date is currently
set for March 1st 2023 this date comes
after the game was initially pushed back
from its original June 2022 window last
year following the decision to shift to
Unreal Engine 5. it's unclear too
whether at this stage the release date
is just for the PC version of the game
or not
the day before is looking like a big and
ambitious game coming from a developer
that has had zero experience with
anything on the scale
it has been published by maitona a
company that has only ever had
experience with free to play mobile
titles
looking at all of these factors together
you can't help but be more than a little
skeptical about the game and what's
going on with it behind the scenes
every trailer we've seen so far has been
heavily scripted with no evidence of
regular gameplay
scene seems carefully choreographed to
show the game in action while telling us
very little about what it's really about
it just feels like they are showing
exactly what a lot of us are looking for
in a game but with a distinct lack of
substance to any of the footage other
than some amazing photorealistic scenery
the developer fantastic isn't a
completely unknown developer and has
knocked out some half decent games
and while my toner the Singaporean
publisher is known for making some
pretty big mobile games it doesn't
really say much about the Publisher's
place in making AAA games like the day
before claims it'll be
but it at least shows that there's some
money behind this whole operation
the day before is a game that I really
want to be hyped about but there are so
many red flags that I can't help but
think that it won't even be close to
hitting the type of hype that has
managed to set for itself
I urge anyone who is interested in this
title to refrain from pre-ordering if
this becomes available and hold out for
after day one where others can show what
the game is actually capable of
I really hope I'm wrong as The Gaming
Community is obviously screaming out for
this type of title but the day before at
this stage is set to be either a new
gaming phenomenon or a major
disappointment
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]